le panda une espèce rare mais aussi un
animal diplomatique depuis des décennies
la chine l'utilisent pour nouer ou
améliorer des relations avec d'autres
pays
offrir important en guise de cadeau la
pratique sur tendre mais dans les années
70 c'était courant de la part de la
chine septembre 1973 pour la première
fois le pays accueille un président
français à son retour en france georges
pompidou reçoit deux pandas par avion
ian kelly ce couple de pandas est un
cadeau personnel du président mao tsé
toung monsieur georges pompidou ils sont
depuis samedi dernier les hôtes du zoo
de vincennes et c'était aujourd'hui leur
première apparition devant les caméras
de 24 heures sur l'a eu
à l'époque c'est la guerre froide offrir
un panda est un moyen d'entamer des
relations diplomatiques avec un autre
pays ou bien de les conforter comme avec
le japon à la fin des années 70 les deux
pays s'entendent bien un traité de paix
et d'amitié vient d'être signé en cadeau
la chine offre à pandas au zoo de tokyo
c'est l'effervescence chez les
commerçants
ce nouveau don à relancer la fièvre du
panda fabricants et commerçants ont
réagi en sortant une vaste gamme de
souvenirs et les promoteurs déguisé en
panda sont venus accoster les éventuels
clients
1984 terminé le don de panda désormais
face à la rareté de l'espèce est sous la
pression des environnementalistes la
chine décide de les louer à des zoos
étrangers comme celui de washington en
2000 à l'époque les relations sont
bonnes entre états unis et chine deux
pandas sont loués aux américains coût de
l'opération pour eux 10 millions de
dollars pour dix en avion privé à leurs
couleurs comité d'accueil sponsors sur
chacun dépend de leur cage et
commentaires télévisés pour rassurer la
foule sur la santé du couple
et ça continue décembre 2011 après six
ans de négociations un accord est signé
entre la chine et la france pour
améliorer des relations tendues et
préserver l'espèce deux pandas sont
loués au zoo de beauval là aussi ce
geste diplomatique port a un coût un
million de dollars par an pendant dix
ans à la charge de la preuve est prêt de
pandas c'est une affaire qui se traitent
au plus haut niveau donc entre le
président de la république française
nicolas sarkozy et le président hu
jintao janvier 2012 juan juanlu hens y
arrive en rock star en france tapis
rouge journalistes sur le tarmac
l'ambassadeur de chine en france est
présent pour l'occasion les deux chefs
d'état ont beaucoup travaillé aussi à
leur niveau sur ce projet qui symbolise
à mes yeux l'amitié traditionnelle entre
le peuple français et elles veulent
chinois en août 2000 21 rhône roanne a
donné naissance à deux bébés pandas deux
femelles surnommé provisoirement fleurs
de coton et petites neiges
[Musique]